all right guys bang-bang I've got Julie
here I think social doing this yeah it's
nice to see you again even if it's
virtually for sure so for those that
don't know you let's just start with
your background and kind of what you did
prior to getting to to Bloomberg and
that I mentioned evening yeah so I
started at Bloomberg back in like 2015
and originally I was just a markets
reporter so I covered everything from
like analyst notes on specific companies
or the broader S&P 500 in general things
on currencies commodities good for me
cuz I was a finance major I just liked
the creative aspect of journalism versus
just going into AI banking or asset
management so I did that for about two
years and then I kind of casually
started covering FinTech I think there
was some of the Robo advisors that were
big around the time some like things
like Lending Club they had just gone
public and we didn't have anyone at
Bloomberg that was focused on just fin
tech which kind of like blew my mind in
the sense that if you think about it
Bloomberg is one of like the original
fin tech companies so around
Thanksgiving that year I like wrote this
big memo and sent it to the head of the
newsroom like hey we don't have anyone
covering this you have a lot of people
covering markets right now and here's
some stories that I've done on it in my
free time and why I think our customers
would care about it our audience would
care about it and in general like
there's a lot going on here if we don't
have anyone covering it we're gonna look
really behind because the New York Times
has nathaniel popper the journal has
peter reuter year and other people so
within like a month they moved me over
to the tech team to start covering that
which it was amazing I spent around two
and a half years on that team covering
everything from a lot of Robin Hood's
stories a lot of still some more Robo
advisors story a lot of crypto stuff
hence why we ended up needing because I
was right when I started was around the
crazy Bitcoin bubble I think yeah it was
like it was a December 2017 where
Bitcoin hit its all-time high or like
started getting there and in
member of that year so that Thanksgiving
was the one where I had emailed so
crypto was another reason they're like
oh we actually probably should have
someone covering this this is a good
idea and so it would all it was always
kind of changing a little bit in terms
of what companies I would focus on just
because the space is so huge as you know
so you kind of just had to follow the
news flow a little bit
so the to public companies I covered a
lot more PayPal and square lending I did
a little bit and then like after the
Lending Club Fiasco and things kind of
like just got boring in this space a
little bit you kind of shifted your
priorities to things like Robin Hood
because that was heating up in terms of
reader interest and things like that and
then right before kovat hit as we were
saying in the warm-up here was when I
ended up leaving Bloomberg and it was
like like I love journalism I just was
ready to try something new and kind of
like I was a finance major so I don't
know that I ever thought journalism was
like the career I was gonna retire in
and much like you and your fiance I have
kind of that entrepreneurial spirit and
wanted to try my own thing to do so I
left on March 3rd March 4th it was like
the Tuesday of the first week of March
and I just kind of like I had talked to
a few VCS and stuff before and I knew
they were looking for people to help
them with content help their startups
with different like research and whatnot
like the nice thing about being a
journalist is you have a lot of
different skills so that's great
and then I also am car from FinTech
today reached outs now I do a premium
newsletter that he was planning to start
and was looking for someone to do I was
like hey you should bring me on I'm
happy to do that I love writing a
newsletter was one of my favorite things
to do at Bloomberg because it's kind of
this just like know as you know it's
like really good stuff in it but you
just get to like talk to your audience
it doesn't have to be so professional
and buttoned up and everything you just
have fun with it so each time I write
that every week it's just like me having
a conversation about what's going on in
FinTech why it's important and what
people are saying it means for the
future so you talked about like you can
be a bunch of other things and then I'm
also helping a venture firm right now as
an analyst covering FinTech and health
tech just because on the side
I teach fitness classes and have a
personal training certification so when
people look at FinTech I think that
people in it know exactly what we're
talking about people who don't or like
what the hell is that and so let me talk
a little bit about since you've covered
so much of it how do you think about
that intersection between finance and
technology and basically what falls in
FinTech versus maybe oh that's just like
traditional finance and you know they're
using cloud service but that's not truth
in tech so where's kind of that line or
how do you think about
everyone's gonna give you a different
answer for this - like real estate
sometimes is spin text sometimes in it
isn't and healthcheck is sometimes spin
text sometimes isn't cuz you have like
health insurance aspect of it so a lot
of it is just kind of like figuring out
like how much finance is actually
involved in it because there's piece as
a real estate tech that is very financed
right like title insurance I would think
of as a very thin tech type thing but
our like getting a mortgage I think of
as a very thin tech type thing you have
companies like blend and quicken and all
these guys that are thought of as fin
tech companies but there's other pieces
of it where like I don't know that's
probably like the design tech that's
involved or like pure real estate like
broker tech that's kind of like I don't
really know if that's pin deck it's
getting kind of close to the line but I
think the main things that I always
focus on lending is very much intact
payments is very much thin tech crypto
is but it's almost like so massive and
in itself that part of me thinks of it
like the separate sector of FinTech um
same thing with like blockchain I kind
of put in that a little bit to which
some people will get mad at me about
some people won't get mad at me about uh
I mean what else am I missing in there
those are kind of like the big ones that
I see doand focused on a lot cuz like I
said like square PayPal bro trading and
brokerages I also thought of as fin tech
but that's something it was very hard to
figure out as someone it was a
journalist you know what they shouldn't
instrument cover because like I said
everyone's gonna give you a different
answer and you kind of just have to make
your choice and stick your ground coz no
one can really argue for sure one way or
the other I'm most of it yeah and I
guess as you need to kind of look
through the space there's large
companies that started out as technology
companies working in finance there's the
Challenger banks and all that kind of
stuff that are still startups and doing
that but but also now we're starting to
see more and more large traditional
finance companies from Wall Street start
to build things right obviously Marcus
and and things like that and so maybe
I'll throw out a couple of companies and
you can just walk us through like your
understanding of what are they doing how
is it going
kind of where they fit an ecosystem we
could start with robin hood's that's one
that I know you've covered extensively
and maybe just kind of talk about like
what exactly are they doing and kind of
how do you look at them in the FinTech
industry yeah so I mean they're
obviously very well known and I've done
very well as starting trading platforms
someone that's more of a advanced trader
that wants to do things like like limit
orders and like really like technicals
not like wants to chart things Robin
it's not for them but it's for someone
like it's really easy user interface or
someone like you just have it in the
palm of your hand it takes you like five
seconds to buy 10 shares and McDonald's
if you want to whatever and it's it's
free obviously but that's becoming less
of a advantage just given that like I
have a Schwab account and I had don't
trade me for my trades on that either
they were just the first to do that and
that was their first mover advantage in
that space but right now they still have
a very good user interface and
everything I think the tough thing for
them and it's across the board in terms
of FinTech is cross selling into other
products like I just when I think of
Robin Hood I don't think of someone
that's gonna be my bank account even
though they're trying to do that too
I don't think of someone now I'm gonna
go get a loan from I don't think of
someone that I'm gonna go get a mortgage
from I don't think of someone that I'm
gonna get insurance from which doesn't
necessarily mean that they won't be
successful I just think they have a
choice to make in terms of where like
how broad they want to be and I think a
lot of that also just depends on their
revenue stream like obviously right now
you've seen the numbers from the public
companies in terms of how many people
are trading stocks right now so Robin
Hood's doing really good but how long
does that last and how do they maintain
the growth that they've been seeing now
that they don't have that advantage of
being the only player in the game with
no feet trading yeah and it feels like
square has taken the opposite approach
of starting with the bank and the
payment technologies and then adding in
kind of brokerage services so maybe talk
a little bit about that and that we can
compare the two and kind of which one's
the more sustainable strategy yeah so
one thing you hit on there that I want
to make sure we aren't missing is just
like the rebonding
so the start of FinTech years ago is
people just picked the one thing to
start with and now everyone's trying to
be the exact same thing right everyone
just o wants to be like the Amazon of
financial services where everyone just
goes to this one-stop shop and gets
everything they need and that's really
hard to do is like I said with Robin
Hood I don't I don't know that I would
ever think of them as someone I would go
get a mortgage with or just like have my
debit card for my checking account with
square has been able to do it fairly
well you've seen the numbers on cash app
and now it's starting to generate
revenue much like PayPal is doing with
venmo and the advantages that Square has
it's it's seller network that it started
out with obviously is like that dongle
that you put in your phone for
businesses cuz a lot of cash app users
are also just small businesses that have
accounts on there too they've just
expanded and launched products to get
more consumers like you and me using it
with a personal debit card and now they
have trading on there which is also free
and also has a pretty good user
interface like Robin Hood - there's pros
and cons to each of them that we don't
need to get into same thing with all the
other ones but they they picked a good
time to do that because they did that
late last year and that's right around
when trading started picking up again -
and one of the reason that square stock
is like above $100 and when Co vyd was
that it's like worse I think it was 30
or 40 and I remember a few of my friends
and I debating on buying it we're all
kicking ourselves now because it surged
like to 300% in the past few months and
a lot of that because of things like
cash up and showing growth in places
that people hadn't thought there was
gonna be this strong growth before I
think squares now like a 50 billion
dollar company if I remember correctly
really other day and and when you look
at that it feels like this whole idea of
rebonding right when I compare Robin
Hood and squares like Robin Hood's
starting with brokerage to your point
it's very hard to add other things
square though it feels like they can add
anything right they've got deposits and
if you have deposits that's kind of
feels like that the foundational core do
you agree with that or disagree yeah no
I think so too and it's it's weird I
don't know exactly why there's some
firms that we can think of as adding
different things and we would
be more apt to use them or not I think
Robin Hood is just so known for its
brokerage that it's just it's hard it
almost would be like if betterment tried
to launch I don't even know what not
like a credit card or something but like
something so different from robo-advisor
that you're like wow this is weird I
don't think of betterment is that I
think of them as like maybe trading
stocks they could get into but largely
like long-term investing maybe a debit
card so you have like a cash account in
there and stuff too and squares just
been really good at picking good times
to launch into new things they have
Square Capital they have their online
network they made the acquisition of
what was it Weebly where now a lot of
their sellers can use that to build
websites and take photos of products and
all these things so that's another thing
like everything as we mentioned before
was moving online so that's also helped
out companies like Square and PayPal
etcetera because now instead of paying
with cash or your Visa card or whatever
even if you're using that but like it's
online payments that are happening
versus going into a store where you
might not be using that yeah and I guess
how does something like squit what
Square is actually building right now
and I think what Robin Hood aspires to
how does that differ from like these neo
banks or challenger big site people who
are putting the flag in the ground and
saying like I want to be a bank right I
mean there's a lot of similarities I
think Square is always going to be more
known as payments than what a neo bank
would be like neo banks I don't see them
ever having a big network like a stripe
or whatever where it's just like an
online platform for processing payments
but there are a lot of other things like
whatever Square cached app is going for
that's something that Anil Bank would go
for too in a sense
cash up is kind of like the largest neo
Bank that no one ever really talks about
we talk about chime revolute monza like
new bank in Brazil whatever no one
mentions Square even though it has way
more users than most of new bank in
Brazil might have more I have to go
double check but I think Square still
has more monthly active users than what
they would so in that sense anything
cash up goes after something in the open
could want and go after - yeah and I
remember Jack Dorsey gave an interview
one time and he really talked about this
idea of like
the reason why he's so bullish on
Bitcoin is every time he goes to open a
new geography there's just a bunch of
obstacles right there's regulation
around banking and you use that word
Bank you know everyone wants a piece of
your business everyone wants to tax you
everyone wants to regulate you and so I
guess part of this is how do these
companies do international expansion
right in the US like it's heavily
regulated and it's pretty well
understood it's just gonna take capital
in time but how does that look going
internationally to Robin who's trying to
go internationally squares trying now
like what does that look like it depends
on which section of FinTech that you
want to go into whether it's payments or
lending or banking I think a lot of it
is gonna be like white labeled through
api's and whatnot so this is kind of an
example it's not perfect for
international but think of what Goldman
is doing with its partnerships with
Apple and Amazon right like you don't
think of Goldman is the one that you're
doing everything with but that's just
Goldman white labeling its product and
using the distribution of Apple and
Amazon right so there's gonna come a
time where Goldman might partner with
someone like Target we can go in at
Target and get a mortgage for Goldman
Sachs and that's a good for both of them
one because it makes Target have more
users coming in and they can use data
get a piece of whatever they're selling
and Goldman gets massive distribution
without having to do a amount a huge
amount of marketing and customer
acquisition cost is huge in financial
services and you also have extra data
points that Target would have on that
consumer to have a better idea of
whether they're gonna pay that mortgage
back or not how reliable they are right
so I think the same thing is gonna
happen in terms of international where
there's gonna be a lot of white labeling
probably some M&A you've seen PayPal do
a lot of M&A overseas in China India
Mexico latam in order to get more flow
over there too because if you look at
for payments in particular a lot of the
cash flow overseas is still literally
cash and not some sort of digital
payment so the gross for someone like
that is gonna come from overseas rather
than the United States borrowing like I
mean kovetz obviously resulted in a lot
of growth right now but in a normal
world
a normal environment the girls coming
from places other than us India and
China what do the legacy players do to
kind of either combat mitigate the
threat from the neo banks and some of
these FinTech tech companies especially
as they see them kind of already not
maybe tapping out penetration in the US
but having enough penetration to then be
you know interested or intrigued by
international expansion right so I think
a lot of it is gonna be end up being M&A
last year you saw visa buy plan is a
good example of a way to kind of
mitigate anything that they might have
done to dismantle or kind of like hurt
them in the process because they are
players that are getting bigger
same thing with Intuit and credit Carmen
I should mention that like those aren't
like officially done yet but they're
announced they're just undergoing like
regulatory approval and stuff so that
one as well is one where you just see so
much the potential now that you're
starting to see big good acquisitions
most of them aren't gonna be that big
they're gonna be much smaller and it
could be another FinTech buying another
FinTech versus an incumbent buying a
FinTech so I think that's one trend
that's gonna help with that a lot of
these firms in the past like five years
or so have opened venture arms that are
continuously getting more aggressive in
terms of funding and partnering with a
lot of the firms that they can get
information from and then really just
like helping add more of their money
towards research and other things to
kind of figure out where the ball is
going next
I think it's Jamie Dimon usually
mentions this isn't in his annual
shareholder letter talking about how
much money JPMorgan is spending on
innovation all these other things now
and that if you look over the past years
like it's significantly picked up and
it's because of FinTech and all the
stuff that we see every day going on
behind the scenes like there's a reason
now all of a sudden more of our friends
have apps from venmo or cash app or
chime or whoever on our phone and don't
have like a chase app on our phone and
stuff right so like that's not a trend
banks like to see and they're gonna do
everything in their power to make sure
that
they don't get disintermediated how does
stripe fit into all this
Dre stripe stripe could do a lot to
that's another one like square that I
think there's a lot of room for them to
expand in different things and the thing
stripe has going for them is like I said
most transactions overseas now are still
taking place on cash there's a lot of
room to bring those online and stripes
big motto is increasing the GDP of the
internet it's literally what they say so
if you go after these markets where
they're not using the internet for a
bunch everything's and selling online
and processing these payments online
guess what stripe can come in and go do
a bunch of that stuff they've expanded
more recently having like a recs type
credit card for companies they've
started lending stripe ijen has a VC arm
itself and there's a lot they could end
up doing and I mean even the two
founders there's a lot of room for them
to do things politically and everything
- in terms of just like fundraising and
no speaking a lot for the space in
general stripe and Square both obviously
have payment data and they're starting
to kind of flex their muscles there we
also see Amazon doing this where people
are saying wait a second if I understand
your payment data then I can probably
better predict lending to you or
providing capital to your business or
organization how do you think about that
in the evolution of just like what
people can do with the data and to
create other business lines in the
future yeah I mean if you sell it you
should make sure that it's all you know
tokenized anonymized it's such or to
make sure it's saving your customers
don't get freaked out by that because
trust in financial services is extremely
important but otherwise there's a lot of
room for companies especially in an
environment as hard to lend in right now
where you can sell some of that data
that makes it so they're that much more
likely to make the right loans and know
what kind of loans people would be
looking for and target the right
customers whether that's good or not is
debatable and I can see both sides of it
but in any case there's a lot of room to
use that right now because if you think
about it everything from like a credit
score is getting so much more
complicated with all the things that are
going on around
it's not just these basic things now
like how many credit accounts you have
and how up-to-date on payments you have
been on them there's like all these
other little things around there I'll
turn into data big data whatever so
there's there's gonna be a lot that's
going on there and there's a lot of both
smaller and medium-sized startups in the
space that are trying to have API
products that can sort of analyze that
and help firms better understand their
customers and who they're lending to
market Driessen obviously famously said
software is eating the world it feels
almost like software is like really
eating finance right now they're kind of
walking down feature by feature product
by product that a traditional bank would
offer is there a world in the future
where companies just use a stripe or a
square and that is there financial
services provider everything from
accounts to credit cards to lend it I
mean just like the entire suite of
services you would get at a bank or
replaced by these kind of digitally
native offerings 100% I would think you
get there sooner rather than later to I
think like the target example I
mentioned there's gonna be time where
you can walk into Apple and get a
mortgage and they might do something
where like hey like we can give you this
right now but if you buy a new iPhone
and you make the payments for another
year we can give you a discount on your
mortgage on a better rate and like all
these little things based on the extra
data that they're gonna have around you
and I that's me saying apples not gonna
become a bank it's up but it's gonna
partner with someone that can goldman
JPMorgan or whoever and be able to offer
that 100 in the next five to ten years
100% that's gonna happen and when you
turn with Apple it almost feels like
Apple I'll make a very crazy connection
to Trump where Trump kind of went from
developer a real estate developer to
wait a second um use my name and I'm
gonna license it and put it on all these
buildings and like now I have a bunch of
buildings it feels like Apple is doing
that a little bit in finance right where
they originally started out building
products themselves usually hardware
they're not moving into services but in
finance specifically they're just using
the IP of the Apple name and slapping it
on to all of these services up so they
vetted but that's really what their
strategy seems to be is like let's use
our brand but
use other people as partners to deliver
this and take a piece of the business
yeah essentially and I'm gonna do two
comparisons here to kind of help yours
understand like there's different paths
to this so Apple has pretty much
entirely around finance gone with the
partnership angle whoever it might be
with whereas uber we've read in recent
weeks very much tried to build a lot of
this in-house and a week ago they got
rid of a lot of people on there uber
money team and like the head of it left
there scaling it down and they're gonna
do things through partnerships instead
and that just shows to me that building
things internally is hard it's expensive
its time-consuming and you're probably
not going to end up with a product that
is as good as partnering with a firm
that focuses on that and that's their
core competency right lewbert's core
competency is never gonna be financial
services it's just gonna do that through
partnerships now and I think that's the
smarter route for a lot of these
companies I don't think they should end
up building a bunch of FinTech
internally I think they should do it
through partnerships if they haven't
started building finance already and
even in some cases if they already have
helped me understand like why is he very
interested in financial services like
what's the what's the advantage for
somebody who I wouldn't think as a bank
or financial service provider why do
they want to get into that a lot of it
isn't for you and me it's for their
drivers they could definitely do stuff
for you and me in the future too
but in some foreign countries they're
goober drivers are still paid in cash
Elan it's really dangerous because
people will try to rob and kill those
drivers because they know there's gonna
be a lot of money in the car other
things is getting your payments either
right after the drive is done or at the
end of the day rather than having to
wait 1 2 3 weeks to get your paycheck
and that's huge for a lot of them in the
sense like they might have to go get a
payday loan if they don't get that money
right away so real-time payments is
another reason that that's a big thing
and I don't know that they ever found it
as a massive revenue driver it's just
such a competitive market with lyft and
others out there that it was a good
differentiating factor for them as well
and a safety factor for their drivers
which is something
you really you don't want lawsuits
around stuff like that that just looks
really bad for sure
what you're talking about is something I
call streaming payments right this whole
idea of like get paid at the end of the
day and I was shocked there's a company
that we invested in called the Brigid
basically their whole idea was the top
four banks I think it is made like eight
billion dollars last year in overdraft
fees and so they're you know tell us
about it I'm like well why is that and
like well basically what ends up
happening is most people who get hit
with overdraft it's nothing you don't
have the money it's that there's a
misalignment between you know Netflix
bill comes on the twelve you go grocery
shopping number thirteen the car payment
on the fourteenth paycheck hits the
fifteenth well you actually have the
money on the fifteenth but it was just
the literally the dates are misaligned
and so people do is they just budget
into their monthly budget overdraft fees
and like that's pretty insane so what
they do is they do
I think it's $10 a month subscription
and like they'll use machine learning to
prevent you from ever over drafting but
one of the things they said is like look
the Holy Grail actually is just pay
people at the end of the day right don't
wait there come every two weeks and it
feels like that's much more of a
technology problem than it is
companies don't want to do it or
regulations in the way or anything like
that
if is that accurate or income just like
how do you think about paying people at
the end of each day ya know it's
regulation has a little bit to do with
it but a regulation usually catches up
afterwards and there's no reason that a
regulator that I can think of would say
no we actually don't want you paying
people every single day there would be a
lot of backlash or something like that
if the CFPB decided no this isn't a good
idea a lot of it is just that when the
payment networks that we used were built
like people had one bank account people
didn't need to move money around all the
time and now there's just so much more
urgency around moving your money where
it needs to be getting the money in a
timely fashion and these little networks
just weren't built for stuff like that
so you kind of have to build things
around the network's to make it so that
can happen so one example of kind of in
this area is chime Paigey two days early
and it's not really it's kind of giving
you alone but not really it's just that
the payment takes so long to go through
think that the bank's just holding on to
it for two days before it shows up in
your account so they're just taking away
that lag time so it's not like they're
doing anything magical or whatever it's
just they've built around the rails and
give you the money faster and I think
you're gonna be seeing more that Bowles
from the company level as well as some
government agencies both in the US and
international are focusing a lot on
real-time payments as well and it feels
like maybe ven Mo's doing something
similar where you can basically not pay
anything and take three to five business
days to take money from your account
into your bank account but you could pay
these with one or two bucks and they'll
do it instantaneously and so is that
kind of similar in terms of just trying
to remove friction from the legacy
system through these FinTech companies
yeah that's very similar and I think
that fee that venmo another charge will
get super competitive and we'll it won't
go down completely to zero but it'll
basically be at cost for whatever it
costs venmo and others to make it so it
gets there within a few hours versus
waiting like you said two three four
business days lending what are you
seeing there and kind of who are the
players lending the last few months has
been intense just like in terms of
thinking about who you lend to and
everything no one can underwrite in this
environment not for businesses not for
people nobody like what do you any
credit model you had before Kovan hit
you might as well just throw that out
the window cuz it does not matter right
now well it's like 30 plus million
people unemployed no restaurants able to
open in a lot of markets and even if
they do they can only open at certain
capacity and whatnot you can underwrite
in that and company square stopped
underwriting loans the only loans have
been doing our PPP loans for the past
few months because their internal
signals really it it's sends like this
red signal out when it's like the
system's saying like you know it's
getting really hard to underwrite based
on these signals right now you might
think about slowing down a bit they
ended up having to completely stop same
thing with cabbage cabbage ended up
laying off for furloughing a bunch of
their staff and just doing PPP loans
because it's just like there's no way to
tell right now you also have to remember
in lending there's a lot of questions
you're not allowed to ask if if you
could walk into a room not even see the
person that you're lending to but
ask all the questions you'd really want
to ask putting regulation aside it would
be a lot easier to underwrite than what
it is right now and that's both good and
bad things so like race really shouldn't
matter what kind of job you have whether
it's service or not really shouldn't
matter but like service in particular
right now it matters because that person
if they're our waitress they might have
a good credit or from working a lot
before but right now they're not making
a lot of money and you can't really
under eight to that because you aren't
going to be able to tell as quickly that
they're not earning money right now like
credit score is not going to factor that
in they've paid off their credit cards
and paid off a mortgage before because
they were making money but you're not
allowed to know if their service now
certain so you can't know what zip code
they're you got you can know what zip
code they're in but there's certain
rules like zoning laws where you can't
be like well you know what this is a
really bad area it's got like government
housing and everything you really want
to be careful about lending them you
can't use that so there's just so many
factors right now making lending very
hard that I think some of the
alternative data and big data that we
talked about earlier is like extremely
important right now and even I mean I
just feel for people like immigrants and
everything to because it was hard enough
for them to get credit scores in the
first place and now it's gonna be that
much harder because you want to be so
careful around different things so
Lending's a little bit of a mess but I
do feel like having gone through a lot
of this it's gonna come out stronger on
the other side issues so there's gonna
be a lot of them that get weaned out
along the way yeah it's really
interesting to hear you talk about it
because it almost feels like I don't
know 20 years ago there was very little
data and people were basically having to
rely on the person who wanted to borrow
money what information they gave them
maybe it could verify some of it but
like super bureaucratic super slow there
was this like big swing towards oh my
god now we have all this data on the
internet like give it all to me and now
it almost feels like we're kind of
getting back to some level of
equilibrium where people are being told
hey I know you have access to all that
information but you can only use some of
it for the underwriting process is that
accurate yeah yep you can't use
everything you know about the person for
the underwriting process
yeah and I guess how does that change
today right so like what are the
regulations that some of these lenders
are facing in terms of you mentioned
alternative data like every day it feels
like there's new some new source some
genius somewhere comes up with like oh
well if I you know get the zip code and
then I get this piece of data and get
this piece of data and my machine
learning model comes up with you know
this ranking and they start to use it
like how does that regulation work and
kind of what do you see as the
frustration from the FinTech companies
side in terms of interacting with that
regulation yeah I think you're gonna
have to have there's certain firms like
Tala and others that focus a lot on
alternative data and you can like
outsource like white label that software
to make it so other places can better
under it as well other things we this
was our topic in FinTech today this past
week is you've seen the Apple card start
a program or if you don't get approved
the first time they'll walk you through
something and give you tips to improve
your credit score and hopefully get
approved again in four months time like
every week every month I forget what the
exact time for me is they they email you
new tips and everything just like no one
fully understands like why their credit
score is what it is right and your
credits you could have two people with
the same credit score same 800 but if
they have four pieces of credit history
versus twenty pieces of credit history
the 20 piece credit history is way
better off than the other one because
they've shown 20 times that they can
make payments and like manage their
finances and everything so in a way like
the 820 Eric you could make that like
700 at 20 versus the 800 person at 4 and
the 700 again approved in you're like
wait a second like my credit scores 100
100 more why am I not the one getting
approved so that's like in the future no
one's gonna understand how everything
works and you're going to need these
firms falls to the business and to
people like you and me or businesses
okay like why why am I not getting
approve this can you like explain to me
help me figure it out so you have
programs like apples doing that chime
just rolled that out too it's sort of so
one is to better understand to a lot of
their customers a lot a neo bank
customers are you
and younger people don't like using
credit cards so it's a debit card that's
disguised as a credit card kind of if
you put money from your checking account
in there and you can only spend that
amount of money so you're building
credit history by using it but you're
also not allowed to go overspend and all
of a sudden you have it like $5,000
credit card bill and you're like oh my
god why did I buy all that stuff from
Bloomingdale's or whatever it might be
so I think those are two separate areas
so like alternative data and explaining
to both the business and the consumers
like both sides of the transaction why
things are the way they are and then I
think also helping people build their
credit is going to be another area that
is very beneficial in the future because
financial literacy has been a big thing
in FinTech for a while there's so much
more that we can do in it that we aren't
doing and to be honest it's almost been
helping the wealthy more than it's been
helping the non wealthy because I'll try
to charge for their financial literacy
and all these kind of things so it's
like there's got to be a better way to
do it and I think FinTech 2.0 if they
want to call it that is gonna be an area
where that's something that a lot of
companies focus on and it almost feels
like it's a win-win right in the sense
if you're helping the user and then
you're also getting them in a position
where you have more comfort whether it's
lending to them having them as a
customer or whatever right right yeah I
mean if they're better able to
underwrite and they're not gonna have as
many losses that's a win for the company
and if the customer has a better
experience with them and is able to be
more comfortable using more financial
services products then that's a win for
them as well how do you see things like
loyalty points and kind of all of the
other perks that are there economic in
some sense but really they're kind of
marketing schemes how has that
intersected with the FinTech world or
maybe it has it at all yeah that's
something I actually haven't thought of
too much I think the FinTech last couple
years our idea of loyalty points was
these high interest savings accounts
because after the financial crisis you
get like zero percent on your chase
checking and savings and then all of a
sudden Marcus and others so we can give
you two plus percent interest rate on
your savings
come here so that was almost our idea of
loyalty points the past years now that
interest rates are lower if they want to
have some idea of loyalty points they're
gonna have to figure out something else
because I think the best out there right
now my markets account I think it's
still like 1.2 or 1.3 but it was all the
way up to like 2.5 so it's easily been
cut in half and then there's other ones
that are even lower than that at this
point so they maybe got something they
should be thinking about new ways to get
loyalty points are they basically
putting it up high at like 2.5% to
incentivize users to join and then like
intentionally bringing it down or is
that actually tied to things like
interest rates and and kind of the more
macro economy stuff it's mostly tied to
interest rates in macro economy so I
actually didn't know this at first when
I started covering this but you're not
allowed so say I am Marcus and my
partner for that is giving me 2% on the
money that I'm giving to them I can't go
lend that out at two point one I can
lend it out at two and lose money with
like all the stuff that goes on behind
the scenes but I can't give the user a
higher interest rate than what I'm
getting on that product so it's like
other places are just keeping that
interest rate money for themselves so
that's why when Marcus lowered it it
wasn't like because they're just like oh
yeah we got you in let's lower it now it
was because they literally legally had
to lower it got it so obviously that's
kind of a negative side effect in some
way of this economic kind of shock
another thing that presented itself was
this opportunity around all the PPP
money that was gonna be handed out there
was plenty of legacy banks that were
kind of primed and ready to help
facilitate getting that into the hands
of businesses and people but also fin
tech companies seem to have stepped in
so like what did you see in terms of
those fin tech companies kind of
scrambling to try to participate and
capture some of that upside right so
they scrambled to help with the first
round but if you remember the first
round the money was gone in like two or
three days and they basically got
approved on the last day so I don't
think if Square and those guys were able
to do a loan it was probably like five
loans or something like very negligible
but they since the money went so fast
they rightly assumed that there's going
to be another
and of this so they continued building
and making sure everything was ready and
lo and behold I forget what the time
dream was in between Jai thing was like
one or two weeks and then the second
round kicked in and there's still some
money left in that round they just
extended it and they if you go on Jackie
Reese's Twitter feed I haven't checked
it lately but she tweets out recent
updates square report earnings again in
about a month and I'm sure they'll talk
about it a lot on there and I mean it
was a big scramble behind the scenes but
it was also something that was both a
smart business decision and a smart
decision just for like the US economy as
a whole like square and Jackie are very
passionate about the small businesses
that they helped fueling our economy
like they end up meeting some of the
people that use their product and have
help from it so it's it's both like a
business purpose as well as like
internally just like feeling good about
what they're doing and employee morale
obviously if employees on Square Capital
team are saving small businesses in
America through this program they're
feeling pretty good about their jobs and
they're not gonna leave anytime soon but
it was a scramble behind the scenes and
something that we didn't realize as
consumers is that the guidelines for
we're just changing not by the hour but
like the day so you'd be building this
product and then all of a sudden the
guidelines change and it's like alright
I guess we basically have to start from
Ground Zero again and that just happens
constantly and you're redoing a bunch of
different things so they were working
weekend square even did something where
people on other teams could volunteer
when they weren't working on their other
team to help the square capital team
like that it was just all hands on deck
on this because like in a way this was
kind of fintechs moment to be like we're
a level playing field with JP Morgan and
City right now like we're just we're not
just startups that like are over here
doing their own thing not a big deal
like we are helping save America right
now and we are not gonna miss this
opportunity they weren't gonna let that
happen so that's like a perfect example
of FinTech really stepping up to the
plate and from what I've seen so far I
mean the program's not over people have
to like go through repaying and like all
these different kind of stuff but in the
initial scenes looking at it like I
think they did really well
yeah it's it's really really fascinating
we've talked a lot about companies based
here in the US and kind of going
internationally but what's going on
internationally in terms of companies
that started out there may there be
trying to come to the US or just kind of
staying in their home markets depends on
what they do so a lot of the Neo banks
that started over in the UK are trying
to expand or not just UK but like UK and
eurozone are trying to expand and it's
just cuz the market is pretty small
there if you look at Asia things like
oddly paying stuff they're pretty fine
just staying over in Asia there's some
things where they want to make it so Ali
pay users in Asia can easily be able to
use hourly pay in the US and Europe and
elsewhere but they don't really need to
have big ambitions to like take over the
US market either and even the neo banks
that are now moving into places like the
u.s. from overseas I don't think they
necessarily think that they're gonna
overtake neo banks that are also here
they just wanted to increase their
customer base and I don't know that it's
really working that well or that there
really was that large of a market that
they could target here
I'm just given that the banking system
in the US isn't terrible like it is in a
lot of other company countries like one
of the reasons new bank in Brazil does
so well is the banking system pretty
shitty in Brazil so there's a lot more
growth opportunity there then they just
expanded to Mexico about a year ago
I'm sure they'll try to expand to
another market and stuff too but like
usually when you start in a certain
country that country is always gonna
pretty much be your bread and butter
make sense
what about supporting multiple
currencies so a country obviously if I
start the United States that's what the
US dollar I don't really have a huge
need to support other currencies but the
second I start to go kind of
international expansion from my home
country that becomes an issue like what
have you seen there yeah so place it
places like stripe and add-in and others
they all have to have multiple
currencies available for processing on
their platform because they're gonna
have users that are buying things from
other countries in businesses they want
to support in other countries same thing
with companies like PayPal and others
and one thing I've been looking into
lately especially just given the remote
or trend is they might have employees
that end up moving to other countries or
hiring more in other countries because
it's like well you're not going to be
coming to the office the office anyway
so if you want to move to Canada you
want to move to Europe you want to move
to Mexico like we still want to keep you
as an employee and there's a lot that
goes on behind the scenes in terms of
moving the money between country and
country like if you go to your bank in
the US and you want to send money to
someone in Mexico it's like five
different banks that end up handling
that transaction it's not just my bank
that I directly go to and then the bank
that that person goes to so that's
something I think there's a lot of room
for innovation from and you see a lot of
earlier startups in that space looking
to be like hire anywhere in the world
you want pay your suppliers anywhere on
where in the world you want like make it
fast there's not a ton of fees all these
different things I think that's an area
of payment that hasn't seen as much
innovation as like online payment
processing all right that brings us to
crypto and Bitcoin what uh what the hell
is going on there in the FinTech world
oh sorry you broke up for one second I
said again I said that brings us the
Bitcoin and crypto what uh what the hell
is going on there in in the FinTech
world it's been pretty stable shockingly
I check it like once a week or whatever
because when it's so phi when they
launched crypto said if you bought $10 a
Bitcoin they would give you 25 I think I
was like I haven't onin a Bitcoin I'll
buy $10 I've been get 25 so I kind of
like randomly look to check it out I
think my $35 is worth like 45 or 50 now
so I'm up on it a little bit but I it's
stable and I think that's a good thing
and I think you would I should ask you
this question what's going on in Bitcoin
and crypto you're gonna have better
answer than I would on this one but I
think the stability is good because it
shows that there is more of like the
volatility just made it so it was just
gambling and people like the the version
of crypto that was happening before was
like this stuff on Hertz when it was
going bankrupt and all these Robin Hood
traders and day traders were like oh
well like we're just gonna buy a bunch
of this just in case like that was
crypto a few years ago they're like oh
like everyone's getting
on this I'm just gonna pile on it like
true crypto believers don't want that to
happen so I think the stability and
everything has been good I think
something to watch should be Facebook's
Libra or its renamed or something not to
see a bag I need to focus on things they
renamed the wallet from Calibra to to
Novi I think it is which Mike Novogratz
swears is because they named it after
him well let him keep thinking that that
should be good luck though no regrets is
done pretty well in the crypto space so
maybe they did is a good omen for the
future of it but yeah I think that's
important to watch bowls from and Inter
a consumer interest in it as well as
what governors and regulators across the
world end up doing with it too because
that I remember one of the final things
I did at Bloomberg was help cover that
and go down to DC to see David Marcus
testifying David Mark Zuckerberg go
testify and a lot of the skepticism that
they faced here is same things that they
faced in other countries but isn't
necessarily a bad thing I think you
should have a lot of skepticism because
this is something that could become
really big if it did indeed worked and
we want to make sure that we do it right
but I think that's kind of what I'm
focused on in this space now too
you do see more companies adding crypto
to their platforms like I think PayPal
and venmo added the ability to buy or
sell Bitcoin on their square did that
years ago Robin Hood did that a few
years ago we did a story on that and I
think it's something that they're
realizing might not be like this massive
thing for them right away but there's
potential for in the future and you
don't want to be caught like off-balance
but oh well we should have been building
this two or three years ago and now we
have to play a lot of catch-up that
sucks so we definitely seen square
current I think it's nine figures of
revenue on a quarterly basis I believe
now we're off Bitcoin alone any idea how
Robin Hood is doing when it comes to the
crypto part of the business and then
also if they're doing well and then
square kind of doing very well does that
serve as kind of this like example where
other people say oh well if they're
doing so well like we have to get
that game because we don't want them to
take all the profits right I don't think
it's quite there yet but it definitely
those would be once to watch if all of a
sudden it did take off in there you'd
100% see others quickly doing that too
rather than kind of passively
researching it for Robin Hood since they
are private it's hard to tell exactly
what the numbers are but from my
understanding their biggest revenue
driver comes from the obstinance trading
on their platform and then you have
stocks and crypto has never been really
huge for them people still think of
coinbase and others is their main
trading for that and I don't know that
they ever thought it would be huge maybe
since they built it right when Bitcoin
was going crazy they initially did but I
think it became apparent fairly quickly
after that like okay this isn't going to
replace the revenue from other things
it's always going to be a revenue
generator but it's not going to be like
the same thing as options trading at
least at the get-go want to play a game
of lightning around questions the first
one is what is the biggest surprise over
the last four months during this
economic shock review the biggest
surprise oh man mmm I think the biggest
surprise for me is the interest in
people in trading I get in some ways it
shouldn't be that surprising because
people can't gamble right now and they
they're born and died wanting to do and
their friends are probably starting to
trade so it's a word-of-mouth thing but
just the massive amount of trading we've
seen I think it was forget it was a
trade or Schwab or who but in one of
their most recent earnings reports or
investor releases talked about how in
like the past two or three months they
saw more trading than they did all of
last year and that's an established
platform it's not one that's just
popping up where like a start-up of
course you're gonna see that kind of
growth none of those firms that I just
named they're all public companies
they're not startups that are gonna see
massive growth so that I think that's
the biggest shock for me what are the
two trends that you're looking at and
paying attention to that people wouldn't
expect over the next year mmm I think
general so that we both get caught up in
like the FinTech world so it's hard to
imagine what like a person that isn't in
this space we get surprised but but I
think the way
labeling software thing that we talked
about where you could walk into a Target
or an apple and apply for a mortgage I
think that's something that we should
watch is gonna happen it would be very
surprising and then the other one I
would say is probably I like the trend
of payments overseas with employees cuz
I think there are gonna be a lot of
people that maybe if Donald Trump gets
reelected and immigration policy stays
super strict and there's a lot of
companies that want to hire engineers
overseas they're gonna have to figure
out a better way to pay them and have
these systems and even if immigration
does get better and there's people that
just want to move to Canada Mexico
wherever and want to keep working at
their company you're still gonna have to
figure out a way to pay them so I think
though that's the other one that is a
trend that I'm watching that you could
see a lot of innovation in over the next
five to ten years obviously FinTech
today is excluded from this question
because it's so great but what is the
one place where you get information from
or person that you follow online that is
it very well known but you feel like has
a really good pulse on all of this I
have to go to bat for my colleague Jenny
Serena at Bloomberg no one understands
payments and a number of areas of
FinTech better than that girl there's a
data piece that she did for Bloomberg a
couple years ago explaining how payments
work like the massive system like the
merchant bank and everything and Striped
literally sent that out to employees to
better understand payments at one point
so the fact that this reporter is like
doing this little data thing in stripe
like one of the biggest payments
companies in the world is sending that
out to their employees like she's one
that I think has a really good pulse on
it and does a lot of good deep dives and
not just like fast quick hitting pieces
and stuff to it she's not like when we
think of FinTech reporters we think of
nathaniel popper Rudy Gere all these
other she's not a name that comes up
that much and she really should Julie
you know what we'll put the plug in
there last question for the lightning
round before we go to wrap up is what
has to happen for Bitcoin to become more
prominent in the eyes of what I will
call the legacy FinTech media
like itse pintuck media you said yeah so
like on the media side there's obviously
all the crypto dedicated publications
but in the more kind of traditional
finance publications what what are the
things that should happen do you think
will drive more attention yeah I think
the stability has to continue because
one of the worst things that happen for
like the FinTech media coverage of it
was the craziness that happened and then
all these like pop up online
publications that happen or out in a
rote kind of like crazier story so I
think stability and some more like
mainstream usage and everything - it
doesn't have to be like me going to a
coffee shop and being able to buy
Bitcoin but just like more use cases
that I'm like all right like that makes
sense because Bitcoin as easy as it is
for some to understand still very
complicated for others to understand and
they don't realize like why it has any
value in the first place if I asked my
dad about it he's like what is Bitcoin
worth more than gold like gold something
I can hold and it has value and
everything so I mean there's just like
there needs to be more apparent use
cases for many people to be able to
understand it and I think that and the
stability is gonna be what's gonna get
us to the next level of Bitcoin kind of
like being here to stay
finish up every episode with the same
two questions then you get ask me one to
end it first one is what's the most
important book you've ever read most
important book I've ever read
to win friends and influence people that
was a really good one and I forget
exactly when I read it I think it was
like my last year of college and it just
really it helped me realize that like
people are always willing to help you
but you have to think of what um like
what their kpi's are what's gonna make
them look good what's gonna make them
feel good because if you do that there's
a really good chance like if you're
empathetic towards them they're gonna go
to bat for you you're gonna do a good
job for them that kind of thing same
thing like making your boss watch what's
gonna make my boss look good cuz I want
to do something that's gonna make my
boss look good and you're gonna win
every time simple stuff but but
important aliens believer or
non-believer I didn't see this question
coming um I don't know if I would call
it aliens but like UFO type things or
like things the world like hasn't seen
or understand one harbor son yeah
what about like intelligent life off of
Earth hmm in terms of like maybe I don't
know if I think of like people off the
earth but like other kind of creatures
and animals I would say yeah I feel like
if there's other humans somewhere we
would be really freaked like we're
actually more ready for aliens than just
oh there's humans on this other planet
probably but weird I mean 2020 has
already been weird so maybe that's the
next shoe to drop we're gonna find that
out what is it eight weeks ago now the
US government confirmed those UFO videos
from a while ago and everyone's like
wait a minute why are they doing that in
the middle of a global pandemic just
like oh yeah those were real man I ended
up watching World War Z like three to
four weeks into the pandemic oh my god
like well at least coronavirus doesn't
like make you turn into a zombie in ten
minutes
okay this is still pretty pretty crazy
stuff I love it you could ask me one
question to end what uh what questions
do you have what are your thoughts on
crypto lately I haven't been able to
talk to you about it for a while last
time I really asked you anything about
it was when it was like Goldman Sachs
was looking at trading it and it was
that like 20 grand and all these phrases
what do you think makes crypto
mainstream order the use cases you're
seeing for it
I actually think it's doing exactly what
it needs to do which kind of sounds
weird cuz I think everyone in the last
full run like kind of came in it was
like oh my god price price price price
ID what's going on a u.s. dollar value
the two stats that I pay attention to
are the computing power so the hash rate
that shake runs the network continues to
grow you know pretty exponentially in
terms or not actually exponentially but
like very very fast and so it's some
years it's four to ten X you know type
growth like pretty impressive and so
that's just like a security and like the
economic incentive to run the software
is there and like that's continuing to
become more and more attractive to more
people the other one is how much Bitcoin
has not moved in the last 12 months and
so if you think of bit quite a lot of
people I think think of like the use
cases to go spend it but because of the
depletion area asset like holding it
actually is a use case right because
you're protecting your wealth that gets
inflation and all the other stuff and so
at the end of June I think was like 61
or 64 percent of Bitcoin that's in
circulation has not moved in the last
year and that's the most ever and so
it's kind of like this thing of like
okay like I think that's trending in the
right direction now a lot of people will
argue like okay if no one's actually
spending it and like how does it become
a gold reserve currency and there's all
of these like second and third order
effects of that but to me is just like I
actually look at holding as more
important than spending right now and
it's mainly because if it is going to
become important in the world in the way
that many people think it will like it's
got a lot of growth to go in terms of US
dollar value and so people holding it
signal they think it has future value if
people weren't holding it than like it's
kind of just gonna go sideways and US
dollar terms like forever right so I
think okay now I can spend it and so I
tend to think those are the two metrics
and like at this point I have I'm so far
in the rabbit hole like I could just be
super bias and like those are two
positive data points so like you know
I'm like oh those are important but I
think there's other ones that pay
attention to and seem to be going the
right direction cool so I was right on
the price too bill anything
good estrogen yeah yeah I mean look part
of it is so I've had people Jason
Calacanis obviously investor do girls so
when I told him he's like way to say
you're telling me the last two years
like bitcoins gone from like three
thousand to ten thousand and basically
just swings back and forth in a seven
thousand dollar range and I'd look
through that it was like that was the
negative he was like oh man that's
amazing he's like that's way more stable
than I thought it was it's like you know
so you got a kind of question like what
is stability but I think you and I kind
of think of it as like alright if you're
you know kind of trending in like a
thousand dollar range like that's better
than a seven thousand dollar range and
so you know where can people go find you
on the internet and where do we want to
send the FinTech
today so my twitter handle is just at
Julie rage so super simple and then on
there you'll see a bunch of stuff from
FinTech today and whenever I tweet out
my weekly news or letter I put in the
link to subscribe because I only do the
monthly subscription one which is $25 a
month so not super expensive you get a
lot of good stuff i interview VC's and
stuff in there to kind of keep a pulse
on the space so you goal is to keep you
one step ahead of everybody else awesome
listen thank you so much for doing this
I think you are one of the leading minds
and all this stuff and I'm happy they
you even though you have Bloomberg
you're still writing about it so so
thanks so much do to get the future yeah
FinTech can't get away from me for too
long so thank you so much for having me
on this was so much fun I look forward
to tweeting about it and seeing what the
impact is